what was something that you learned
though
from that experience or maybe from jeezy
that you because you know you've been
doing
independently a lot of boss [ __ ] in the
last you know seven eight years so like
what's something you took from that
experience or from gz directly that
you've kind of applied to
yourself her career now his work ethic
like dude
just non-stop like and that was like my
first time ever being in the studio
to like seven in the morning oh yeah
those are the nights yeah like i never
used to do that i come in the studio
two three hours and i'm gone do what you
gotta do get home so when i was with him
i'm like
why are we doing this like we in the
studio until [ __ ] daylight like i'm
[ __ ] doing i did that [ __ ]
every day and i'm like man this dude is
a multi-millionaire so we gotta
put in double the work right so i
started applying that just going to the
studio every day
yo um talk about because when was the
first project with carter was that 2016
i don't want to say 16 or 15. i ain't
sure
what what inspired you to do uh first of
all
get ricardo and i feel like uh you kind
of
you know have influenced some other
stuff happening in hip-hop right now but
but but i feel like you and cardo
definitely came together and
and uh did your thing man with both of
those projects but
it how did that happen really cheesy
cheesy yeah jeezy um he had flew me out
to atlanta and we was working on a
project with uh
it was gonna be me cardo and yg and
jeezy he was gonna be a group
really it was all carter produced and we
made a whole project
that was hard all right so you cardo yg
and jeezy yeah and that was supposed to
be like a super group it was called like
paid in full or something like that and
you guys did a whole project whole
project we had beats from warren g
daz dillinger what uh dj quick
and cardo did like all other beats and
it was a hard project
but for some reason it never never saw
the day of life yeah but that's where me
and cardo
found our niche like we found our pocket
you know a lot of them nights in them
studios together wow
how many uh how many songs did you guys
do for that project i think we had about
a good
twelve about ten twelve last album yeah
we all had solo songs and uh
group songs it was hard damn uh
when would that see the day of light if
ever i don't know who has that
jeezy jeezy's guys it's up to him he got
on the hard drive
it's on a hard drive just sitting
somewhere yeah that [ __ ] man classic
wow that sounds like that's like one of
them albums it's like
going to be folklore for now every year
yeah that [ __ ] was special i was excited
about that
why yeah are you and yg still keeping
contact i ain't talked to yg in a minute
but that's you know
it's still love for sure no 100 percent
man yeah